y los incendios forestales en eeuu y
rusia se agudizan como resultado de las
olas de calor en el hemisferio norte el
fuego llamado bootleg en la frontera
entre los estados de oregón y california
ya deja más de 80.000 hectáreas
calcinadas y ha obligado a cientos de
personas a evacuar sus casas realmente
quiero hacer énfasis en lo seca que está
esta región y las condiciones extremas
que se presentan ojalá existiera una
palabra más fuerte que extrema para
explicar lo que está pasando porque son
incendios históricos y una sequía
histórica la que estamos viviendo
mientras tanto en rusia los incendios se
han acabado con 800.000 hectáreas de
bosques siberianos la zona más afectada
de yakutia declarada en estado de
emergencia el ejército ruso envió
aviones para luchar contra las llamas y
los incendios han empeorado mucho
alrededor del país debido a las
temperaturas anormales la situación en
yakutia es la más difícil siguiendo las
órdenes del presidente la federación
rusa y el ministerio de defensa están
intentando combatir los incendios junto
con las autoridades locales
en julio canadá registró las
temperaturas más altas desde 1937 y si
las naciones no controlan sus emisiones
para cumplir con los objetivos del
acuerdo de parís de mantener las
temperaturas por debajo del grado y
medio con respecto de niveles
preindustriales este panorama podría
convertirse en la norma